good morning John I'm in a car I'm
headed to work we've got the decide boy
right now being safe and I wanted to
take you with me to appreciate some the
people who work on the things and the
play for the doing
[Music]
you
kind of start with Matthew what are you
doing right now financial diet okay
there's a girl they are so I can't
answer you
hey you good good are you I'm going to
camp I'm in the same spot at the
cameraman yeah I know but if I look
eyeline weird man I lie on the coals
here yeah I'll just pretend like you
hear the whole time hey Nicole I have
been here the whole time but who are you
editing myself yeah I know what that
book series here what are you writing
about right now actually editing
crash-course film a little saddened you
death because she lives in New York
sometimes she was here hi how's it going
good how are you I am reading about ways
to start a new job not as I'm looking
for a new job
but because I'm working on a script I
had of adults thanks for making that
clear yeah I'm coming in
[Music]
you're our newest person I am how are
you doing I'm learning how to edit you
right now well I'm more specifically I'm
learning how to animate on top of you
you wouldn't think there's anything
happening in the darkness over here
there is the dark look at you this is
the darkest I've ever seen it in here
behind this door is the scariest part oh
hey it's Henry hey I did it Here I am
so you are you know working with you
working out this is my office
hi Bryce sorry I ready you dropped into
my house this is the life that they
turned purple when we're filming
Sumerian who is my assistant assisting
with all things hello what are you
working on your emails Thanks how are
they there's a lot of them Alexander
Julie I have Julie what's your official
title Director of Operations money maker
the vast majority of the picture - oh
she should come in a night hi Julia how
are you doing I know how are you cuz
this maps of Amsterdam in Melbourne yeah
I got to think about them we noticed
yesterday that you have an updated to
calendar collection funny you say that
Oh calendar calendar cows doing yoga
rivers ocean available via TV a list no
no no I'm in a while with a that's
even more than I had last year I know
what a cool room you guys have and what
are you working on I'm working on
signage for encounter criteria what do
you have programmer behind it
oh yeah oh dang okay I'm going to take
pictures of all of you and then put you
in my video he's gonna have lower thirds
why are you on the floor I Hank oh it
stops for whatever this is now I'm going
through the warehouse and get the
feeling that our break table isn't being
used
right now tell you you're already in
there you trading out and now I go home
it's weird right
I want to be clear that like
vlogbrothers still just me but all the
other things VidCon scishow crash course
dftba.com all that stuff so many people
are necessary to make it happen I like
doing the business thing and I like
doing it not in the normal ways so I'm
going to keep doing that and I'm excited
for what the future has to hold there a
lot of people who work on the things
that we do and I am always amazed by
them and really lucky to have them in my
life John I'll see you on Tuesday